demain à 14h30 pour le débat
je souhaite mais nous souhaitons
que dans cette institution sénatoriales
le débat soit
comme il l'est d'habitude
chacun défendant ses positions et ses
propos et chacun respectant les uns et
les autres de façon à ce qu'on ait un
débat apaisé et sérieux je ne serai pas
plus long car l'objectif est d'abord de
vous entendre et ensuite nous aurons nos
deux rapporteurs madame chantal de seine
qui est rapporteur pour le compte de
commissions des affaires sociales et
notre collègue philippe bas ici présents
qui rapporteur au titre de la commission
des lois qui vous poseront bien sûr les
questions qu'ils souhaitent et puis
chacun ensuite pourra s'exprimer et
peut-être informé tout le monde d'avoir
laissé la parole à madame de roche que
nous avons 1h30 d'horloge
puisque la commission des affaires
sociales doit se réunir à 15 heures je
parle sous votre contrôle en 15h30 donc
on s'est tenue dans 30 d'horloge merci
même d'orage
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne serai
pas beaucoup plus longue que président
buffet salue tous nos collègues
participa à nos travaux en
visioconférence on va vous laisser
présenter en effet le le débat ou allons
amorcer le débat monsieur le le ministre
pour ma part j'aurai ensuite une
question sur les tests
je lui avais la parole
monsieur le président la commission des
lois cher françois noël buffet madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales hr catherine de roche g le
rapporteur philippe bas madame la
rapporteure pour avis chère chantal de
seine mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs tout d'abord laissez-moi on a
encore le droit de le faire vous
souhaiter une excellente année 2022 vous
remerciant de me permettre de m'exprimer
devant vous à l'heure où les débats
c'est vrai rejoigne le sénat qui nous
ont beaucoup occupé la semaine dernière
à l'assemblée nationale et qui porte sur
un nouveau projet loi le 12e monsieur le
président 12e qui a trait à la gestion
de la crise sanitaire un nombre dont je
ne peux m'empêcher de penser et ce
serait mon préambule qu'il reflète la
vitalité de notre système démocratique
puisque j'ai bien fait le tour avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues notamment
dans les pays de l'union européenne et
douze textes de loi c'est une une
particularité française mais c'est une
particularité que nous assumons et qui
attestent d'ailleurs qu'en deux ans il a
fallu plusieurs fois remettre sur le
métier notre ouvrage
parce que les virus évoluent parce
qu'ils peuvent muter à tout moment on
l'a vu aux quatre coins du monde parce
qu'ils peuvent parfois nous laissait à
penser qu'on a trouvé la martingale qui
permettent de les freiner ou de les
faire disparaître et puis par moments se
rappelle à notre mauvais souvenirs à
travers des délétions sur le patrimoine
génétique viral qui le rendront plus
contagieux ou plus dangereux ou les deux
ou parfois plus contagieux et est moins
dangereux comme c'est le cas du variant
omicron mais il ya une constante c'est
que il ya une coordination qu'on voit
bien d'ailleurs au niveau international
et notamment au niveau européen qui
pousse vers des mesures je dirais qu'ils
font partie d'un même panel a même
arsenal partout autour de nous ce sont
désormais les règles tu passes
sanitaires ou du pass vaccinale ou des
deux qui sont en vigueur certains pays
ont été amenés à prendre des mesures de
freinage plus ou moins importantes et
retentissante sur le quotidien des
français en france nous avons fait le
choix hormis la question du télétravail
qui est près de nantes mais qui est
absolument indispensable de ne pas
fermer des établissements recevant du
public de ne pas fermer plus tôt que
prévu les bars restaurants les
établissements recevant du public nous
avons mis des contraintes en matière de
très grand rassemblement parce qu'on
veut limiter le phénomène de super
contamination qu'une personne malade en
contamine me parce que là ce serait
évidemment un très mauvais coup pour
l'épidémie en revanche nous avons laissé
ouvert tout un tas d'établissement qui
sont dans beaucoup de pays qui nous
entourent faire mais je le dis encore
une fois en préambule quelle est la
situation épidémique d'abord je le
rappelle nous faisons face à deux
variantes distincts et le fameux
variante delta que vous connaissez bien
ce qui est monté dans notre pays à la
faveur de la fin de l'été qui restaient
ensuite qui fait une ascension assez
forte qui a impacté nos réanimation qui
impacte toujours nous réanimation de
plus en plus d'ailleurs chaque jour
sanaa deux mille huit cents patients en
réa désormais en france et qui a atteint
ensuite
un plafond qui est en même temps devenu
un bain un plafond à ces fixe avec un
nombre de contaminations qui n'a pas
diminué et c'est un plateau merci pour
le mot qui me manquent et madame la
sénatrice et donc le plateau nous a mis
en difficulté pendant plusieurs semaines
parce que il avait son lot de cas graves
vairelles deux variantes lte ait
invariants particulièrement invasif chez
les patients qui l'a qu'il contamine il
provoque des formes d'infection basse
pulmonaire avec des syndromes de
détresse respiratoire comme on le
connaît désormais depuis deux ans et il
pousse un certain nombre de patients en
réanimation je le redis ces patients qui
sont en réhab pour le variant delta pour
des patients qui sont pour la
l'essentiel des patients non vaccinés et
pour celles et ceux qui sont vaccinées
ce sont des patients qui sont
immunodéprimées c'est à dire que la
vaccination n'est pas assez efficace
chez eux ce sont les greffés du rein les
greffés du coeur par exemple ou des gens
qui ont des très grosses maladie comme
des lymphomes des leucémies qui rend
leur système immunitaire inopérant
sur ceux de ce point de vue là et je
suis très prudent monsieur prison madame
la présidente continue à la fois du de
la masse de tests réalisés au cours des
derniers jours on est à plus de 11
millions de tests sur une semaine ce qui
explose très largement tous les records
jamais enregistrée par notre pays
sans compter les autotests et
du fait des remontées avec les jours
fériés etc qui rend parfois le
croisement de données difficiles mais il
semble manifeste des normes elle le
variant delta est amorcé une diminution
qui était attendu peut-être par un
phénomène d'ailleurs de compétition avec
le variant omicron qui est plus
contagieux probablement aussi du fait
des mesures même plus sûr plus
certainement du fait des mesures que
nous avons mises en place et notamment
de télétravail jaurès encore une fois
prudents mais ce sera à conforter dans
les prochains jours ce serait évidemment
une nouvelle rassurante pour nos
réanimation d'ici 10 à 15 jours deuxième
variance et le variant omicron très
contagieuse extrêmement contagieux on
peut l'attraper quand on est vaccinés on
a moins de risque de l'attraper mais on
peut l'attraper on peut le transmettre y
compris quand on est vacciné deux fois
moins nous disent les scientifiques que
si on est vaccinés mais on peut quand
même que si on n'est pas vacciné mais on
peut quand même le transmettre il donne
des formes qui sont des formes plutôt
hot que respiratoire c'est à dire ça
vous touche plutôt la région ici que la
région basse pulmonaire dont qui donne
moins de détresse respiratoire donc ils
envoient moins les patients en
réanimation par contre il peut quand
même donné des syndromes fébriles à
s'est cognée des tous des syndromes
grippaux à ses formes et il entraîne lui
une augmentation conséquente des
hospitalisations sur des sujets jour
dont nous voyons avec suffisamment de
recul désormais qu'ils sont
effectivement plus court que avec les
variants précédent les patients qui vont
à l'hôpital peuvent être jeune il ya
beaucoup de trentenaires dans les
hôpitaux qui sont atteints d'une forme
et autres non vaccinés 1 je le redis et
et qui vont avoir des besoins aux jeunes
de 3 à 4 jours et puis ensuite vont
pouvoir sortir dont condé doit
massivement un relais de l'hôpital à
domicile comme nous avons été capables
de le faire lors d'une vague précédente
c'est à dire de prendre en charge les
patients avec de l'oxygène à domicile en
lien avec leur médecin traitant les
infirmiers l'hospitalisation à domicile
de manière à réduire la pression sur nos
hôpitaux et c'est marion micron vous
l'avez vu le film poussée fulgurante il
fait une fouille poussée fulgurante
partout de jeu regardez la carte du mans
le burundi le canada les pays européens
ça a démarré cette fois ci en allemagne
avec un peu de délai mais ça a démarré
l'italie l'espagne tous les pays qui
avaient même ce qu'avait et épargner
plus ou moins par delta flambe sous le
sous l'effet dû aux microbes et ça j'ai
envie de vous dire quasiment quelles que
soient les mesures de gestion ou de
freinage qui ont été mises en place on
voit que ce variant il trace sa course
et ils évoluent très fortement en est
monté à des trois cent mille cas
diagnostiqués dans notre pays ce sont
des chiffres hors proportion par rapport
à tout ce qu'on a connu depuis le début
de la pandémie et heureusement
heureusement un nous sommes très
vacciner et de ce variant il est moins
dangereux je leur dis une fois que on
l'a on l'a attrapé la question qui se
pose c'est quand est-ce qu'il va arrêter
sa course folle
le modèle que nous suivons tous avec
attention au niveau européen on a une
grosse coordination là dessus ces
modèles anglais puisqu'il a démarré en
angleterre avant de démarrer en france
et je regardais que notamment dans la
région londonienne là où ils avaient
frappé en premier il baisse après avoir
eu une augmentation très très forte une
vague très vives il a commencé à baisser
et de manière assez rapide ce qu'on
avait aussi constaté en afrique du sud
je ne peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui
qu'ils baissent dans notre pays ce
serait excessif de ma part et je me
garderai bien de faire un pronostic pour
les raisons évoquées un le nombre de
tests a explosé et donc ça peut modifier
évidemment les critères de comparaison
d'une semaine sur l'autre et de on a eu
toutes les remontées de données avec les
jours fériés et c'est donc nous verrons
dans les prochains jours si comme les
anglais nous atteignons un pic et
ensuite si ça entraîne une baisse ou si
ça fait comme delta un plateau ce qui
serait évidemment pas est une heureuse
nouvelle donc je reste extrêmement
prudent de ce point de vue là et donc la
charge hospitalière on voit qu'elle
monte on est à 21000 malade aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux et je voulais dit nous
travaillons pour que les patients
puissent sortir plus tôt d'hôpital voilà
pour la partie la partie épidémiologique
pure sur la vaccination vous savez tout
53 millions de nos concitoyens ont reçu
au moins une injection nous avons battu
la semaine dernière leurs records de
primo injection depuis des mois deux
cent trente mille français ont fait le
choix de recourir la vaccination tant
mieux bienvenue à eux les nous battons
encore des records de prise de
rendez-vous en plus d'une prime aux
injections et je le redis aux françaises
et aux français qui nous écoutent les
centres de vaccination nous accueillons
sans rendez-vous si c'est pour votre
première injection c'est trop important
on fait évidemment attention à cela et
nous continuons dans la m dans le même
mouvement les rappels des rendez vous
ont été pris très nombreux pas
d'inquiétude sur les dates de rendez
vous il y avait trois millions de
rendez-vous disponible un peu partout en
france à la date de vendredi soir et
nous y arriverons les tests madame la
présidente je vais pas déflorer la
question que j'allais me posais j'aurai
le plaisir d'y répondre c'est ce qui
arrive lorsque vous mourrez interrogées
a su vous dire juste je ne peux pas
passer outre aussi ceux qui ce que
vivent une certaine attente de nos
concitoyens
depuis quelques jours maintenant
notamment dans le domaine des écoles
avec une politique de tests vous le
savez nous avons fait un choix et qui
est un choix qui est assumée de ne pas
fermer les écoles de ne pas fermer les
classes ou le moins possible ou
seulement quand on n'a pas la
possibilité de faire autrement et cela
va de pair oui avec une contrainte qui
peut être lourde pour ça un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes qui est de
réaliser des tests réguliers chez les
enfants lorsqu'ils sont qu'à contacter
pour éviter de les extraire de l'école
évidemment de travailler en temps réel
avec les scientifiques avec la
communauté enseignante jean michel
blanquer air est totalement mobilisée
pour voir s'il ya lieu d'adapter les
choses ou de simplifier la vie des
français dans la période que nous
connaissons j'en viens maintenant projet
de loi j'irai très vite vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président il s'agit
essentiellement de la transformation du
passani terre en passe vaccinale vous
avez sans doute suivi les débats à
l'assemblée nationale sur la question
des mineurs il ya eu un consensus à
l'unanimité moins deux voix qui a été
trouvé pour n'appliquer le pass
vaccinale co 16 17 ans et de maintenir
le pass sanitaires pour les 12 15 ans
pour les activités dites périscolaires
et extrascolaires tels que activités
culturelles activités sportives il ya eu
des discussions serrées sur la question
du contrôle d'identité nous avons eu
déjà eu l'occasion d'y d'y venir nous y
reviendrons dans les débats en séance
nous pensons que c'est important de
permettre à des personnes qui dirige un
établissement qui reçoit du public de
pouvoir n'ont pas contrôlé l'identité
mais vérifier la concordance entre
l'identité du pass et l'identité
figurant sur une pièce d'identité
haddock toutes ces questions là nous
nous en débattrons je rappelle que le
pass vaccinale ne s'appliquera pas pour
les établissements sanitaires et médico
sociaux c'était une évidence on va pas
empêcher les gens parfois j'ai des échos
de personnes qui me disent on l'a
empêché tel ou tel d'aller voir son père
qui est à l'hôpital qui est très malade
et ses jeunes il n'y a pas de directive
nationale visant à empêcher qui que ce
soit de visiter des proches qui seraient
malades fragiles ou encore moins en fin
de vie il en revanche des règles
sanitaires qui s'applique il faut que
les visiteurs puissent attester du fait
qu'il n'en mèneront pas le virus
amateurs de l'établissement pour ça
qu'il ya cette dérogation de tests qui
est permise mais en définitive il faut
maintenir évidemment l'accès aux
personnes malades ou fragiles pour leur
entourage familial proche vous avez vu
aussi dans le projet de loi nous
renforçons les mesures qui permettent de
lutter contre les fraudes je les dis à
l'assemblée nationale on peut considérer
que le faux-pas sanitaire tu puisque
certains pourcentages de patients
hospitalisés disposer d'un faux pas
c'est à dire qu'il faisait croire à tort
qu'il était vaccinée ce qui entraîne des
conséquences sur la façon dont ces
patients seront soignés tous les
médecins vous le diront ils savent plus
quand un patient vient avec une forme
qui s'aggrave et qui est vacciné
l'évolution le pronostic est donc les
critères de surveillance d'intubation de
mise en commun ne sont pas les mêmes que
quand la personne est pas vacciner quand
on n'est pas vacciné ça va plus vite
l'aggravation ça peut être même subi ça
peut se faire en quelques minutes et
donc il faut être en permanence en
surveillance étroite de ces patients là
enfin le projet de loi aborde des
questions qui n'ont pas de lien direct
avec le texte qui nous occupe c'est la
fameuse question de devises allemande la
contention secteurs de psychiatrie nous
voulons renforcer le rôle du juge de
tension et de liberté à la demande du
conseil constitutionnel et puis je n'ai
pas dit mais il ya évidemment vous le
savez le la déclaration d'état d'urgence
sanitaire la réunion en martinique parce
que la situation sanitaire préoccupante
justifie à nos yeux le maintien des
mesures de prêts nage renforcée je vous
remercie
on peut rapidement monsieur le ministre
si vous pouvez clarifier la stratégie en
matière de tests parce que bon le nombre
de tests explose vous vous l'avez dit la
plupart sont remboursés à 100%
d'ailleurs j'aimerais savoir quel est le
coût actuel de cette politique de test
on le voit bien les pharmacies sursaturé
le système d'information un peu de mal à
suivre avec trois cent mille cas
positifs par jour le contact racing
semble un peu un lointain souvenir et
les familles sont mises à rude épreuve
lorsqu'il faut tester les enfants trois
fois par semaine dans ces conditions
alors certes on empile des records si je
puis dire mais ça illustre un peu aussi
comment les ravages d'une auto
prescription en bourse à 100% et si vous
pouvez préciser la stratégie d'un mesure
où le testing n'a de sens que s'il est
suivi de mesures incohérentes quand on
entend que des soignants sort autorisé à
continuer leur activité que même si sur
testé positif sinon s'ils sont
asymptomatiques
c'était ma remarque et emma questions
merci à présent monsieur rapporte à
monsieur monsieur bah
je vous remercie monsieur le président
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
il ya quelque chose d'un peu
paradoxal dans les débats ces derniers
jours
c'est que on parle exclusivement
d'impasse vaccinale qui en réalité pour
la plupart des français déjà rentré dans
les moeurs puisque le pass sanitaires et
pour eux très majoritairement déjà
impasse vaccinale est par ailleurs face
à une flambée sans précédent de
l'épidémie
on ne peut pas dire que le pass
vaccinale souhaite une mesure
répondant à une urgence sanitaire
puisque il produira ses premiers effets
compte tenu des délais entre la première
injection et la deuxième injection
compte tenu de la date de promulgation
de la loi qui sera je l'espère
rapprocher au mieux à la fin à partir de
la fin du mois de février
et donc je me dis que nous sommes en
train de débattre d'un texte
auquel je ne fais ni excès la dignité ni
excès d'honneur
qui importe sur un sujet important
mais qui n'est en aucun cas une alfa et
l'oméga de la politique sanitaire face à
l'irruption de cette nouvelle urgence
sanitaire
et puisque vous êtes weeds nous c'est
plutôt sur ces questions là que je
voudrais vous interrogez en quoi ce
projet de loi répond il à cette urgence
sanitaire nous sommes nombreux à penser
que la vaccination est essentiel pour
nous permettre de sortir de l'épidémie
et des nombreuses vagues que nous avons
subies mais est ce que c'est un
instrument d'urgence sanitaire ma
réponse est plutôt non mais peut-être
pourrez-vous la démentir
deuxièmement si on rentre dans les
détails le conseil scientifique vous a
alerté dès le mode décembre sur les
risques qu'il a qualifié de
désorganisation sociétale cette
désorganisation nous en voyons
maintenant les effets nous les voyons à
l'école nous les voyons à l'hôpital nous
les voyons dans le système de santé avec
les que pour faire les tests qui sont
souvent exigée pour les élèves eux mêmes
avec un allongement de la durée
d'attentes pour en avoir des résultats
avec une saturation des plateformes de
l'assurance maladie pour dire au cas
contacts ce qu'ils doivent faire
avec des craintes sur la disponibilité
des services et hospitaliers mis à
l'épreuve par l'afflux des malades mais
aussi du fait pour que beaucoup de
médecins il semble qu'il y ait un
consensus entre eux sur le sujet disent
qu'il ya jusqu'à 20 % des lits
hospitaliers qui sont actuellement
fermés faute de personnel
s'agissant enfin de
l'économie le développement du
télétravail a aussi ses limites et donc
au fond je voudrais que vous nous disiez
où on en est pour l'école un protocole
la veille pour le lendemain à mener au
bout d'une semaine la veille pour le
lendemain
une lenteur dans la diffusion des
capteurs de co2
est ce que pour ce qui concerne
l'hôpital puisque je parlais à 100 de
l'école on a déjà prévu la mobilisation
d'effectifs de secours d'une réserve
sanitaire
comment va-t-on s'organiser pour faire
face à un afflux de malades qui pour
l'instant n'est pas au niveau des
principaux pic nous avons connu mais
s'en rapproche
et donc on a beau dire
je crois en effet que les informations
que vous nous avez transmises sont
corroborés par la majorité des médecins
scientifiques épidémiologistes mais on a
beau dire que le vario micron est moins
grave comme il n'y a plus de personnes
qui en sont affectés avec une moindre
proportion de cas graves on atteint
quand même des chiffres en valeur
absolue qui sont très élevés donc voilà
l'ensemble des questions que que je
voulais vous poser au fond ce qui est en
cause c'est l'ensemble de la politique
sanitaire face à l'épidémie s'est pas
simplement la transformation d'un pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale dont nous
aurons bien sûr l'occasion amplement de
débattre ensemble cette semaine
merci sur avatar madame de seine pour la
commune sur la base sociale merci
monsieur le président mon intervention
sera dans la suite logique de
l'intervention de notre rapporteur
philippe bas au préalable je voudrais
rappeler que la commission des affaires
sociales a toujours pris ses
responsabilités
et qu'elle a toujours estimé lorsque les
circonstances l'exigent et que nous
devions faire front commun aux côtés des
scientifiques et des médecins et si le
pass and tax finale pardon est jugé
efficace pour réduire l'épidémie et ses
conséquences nous le soutiendrons
cependant cette stratégie ne peut
réussir que si la campagne vaccinale
atteint réellement toute la population
cible donc ma première question est
simple comment résorber les inégalités
territoriales et sociales qui sont
encore visibles dans la vaccination des
français comment atteindre les non
vaccinés qui doute qui sont en marge des
systèmes de soins je pense en
particulier aux plus précaires aux
bénéficiaires des restos du coeur et
autres soupes populaires mais aussi aux
associations caritatives pour qui le
passent sanitaire actuellement ne
s'applique pas où est le fameux aller
vers temps promu et quel est votre
action spécifique à destination des
outre-mer où le faible taux de
vaccination est mise en avant pour
justifier le retour à l'état d'urgence
autre question le port du masque en
extérieur a été suspendue dans le
courant de l'année 2021 au motif d'une
faible efficacité
scientifiquement constater quelles
données scientifiques justifie
aujourd'hui le retour d'une port du
masque en extérieur
dans le cas de la dérogation la
vaccination va finale après une
contamination
quelle durée et quel niveau de
protection les autorités sanitaires
reconnaît-elle
concernant les immunodéprimés
quelquefois c'est souvent
malheureusement le seul traitement l'a
pas la seule possibilité relève du
traitement et non de la vaccination où
en est la recherche
et est ce que de nouveaux traitements
pourraient être autorisés en accès
précoce et puis je voudrais revenir sur
l'article 1er bis à qui crée un régime
de sanctions administratives applicables
aux employeurs qu'ils ne prendraient pas
les mesures de prévention nécessaires
pour limiter l'exposition au co vide
je suis assez réservé sur 7 sur des
nouvelles sanctions pour les entreprises
estimant qu'elles ont été très actives
et qu'elles ont mis en oeuvre les
mesures sanitaires qui s'imposait en
particulier le télétravail
donc ma question
comment pouvait il faut ça pouvait vous
monsieur le ministre nous indiquer
précisément sur quels critères se
baserait l'inspection du travail pour
prononcer les sanctions prévues et
comment seraient appréciées dans ce
cadre les recommandations du
gouvernement sur le trail télétravail
qui reste une recommandation au milieu
d'un certain nombre d'autres comme la
mise à disposition d'équipements de
protection pour les salariés je vous
remercie merci à ma porte a laissé la
parole à monsieur le ministre en
informant tout le monde qu'il y à déjà
aux collègues inscrits pour des
questions et que nous est plus
interneuron un membre de la commission
des lois avant de la sphère sociale bien
évidemment et on fera par 4 1 et on
essaiera de se tenir dans le temps
monsieur lui disait parle je vais
répondre rapidement comme ça ça
donnerait du temps question même la
présidente de roche ou ai posé la
question fait qu'elle est une stratégie
en matière de test aujourd'hui que je
vais être très clair
on a un double objectif
ne pas paralyser le pays et ne pas
laisser flamber l'épidémie et on a un
impératif nous répondons à la demande en
test des français si nous n'étions pas
en mesure de répondre à la demande des
tests des français on nous le
reprocherait c'était le cas il ya deux
ans donc à deux ans on nous disait vous
testez pas assez par rapport à ce qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui commence à monter
la petite musique de vous tester trop
c'est pas parce qu'on trouve beaucoup
contestent trop
c'est parce qu'on trouve beaucoup
contestent beaucoup
c'est parce qu'on vous trouve beaucoup
contestent beaucoup donc nous avons une
politique de tests qui s'est voulue la
plus ambitieuse possible et qui
permettent aux français d'avoir des
résultats de leurs tests en appel dans
le délai le plus bref possible
gratuitement sauf situations
particulières la personne non vaccinés
qui n'est pas quel contact et qui n'a
pas d'ordonnancé médicale c'est à la
marge
et nous avons voulu une politique de
tests qui se déploient partout et merci
aux pharmaciens merci aux infirmiers
merci évidemment tout ça et c'est aux
médecins qui réalise les tests nous
allons amplifier notre capacité de
réponse à la demande des français en
prenant plusieurs dispositions
complémentaires l'une de ses
dispositions ce sera permettre aux
pharmaciens qui d'ores et déjà vous
savez ont parfois une une tente devant
la pharmacie où on peut se faire tester
et n'ont droit qu'à une seule tente nous
considérons qu'il est pharmacien
souhaite pouvoir employer par exemple
des infirmiers ou d'autres cols d'autres
collègues soignants et non soignants
kabylité à tester ils ont la vocation
s'ils le souhaitent à ne pas avoir une
seule tente d plusieurs voire pourquoi
pas développer de véritables barnum de
dépistage certains nous le demande nous
allons l'autorisé de la même manière
j'ai signé un arrêté qui permet aux
étudiants en biologie de 3e et 4e année
de tête de réaliser de la de participer
également à la campagne de dépistage
pour pouvoir faciliter la tâche de ceux
qui sont mobilisés depuis très longtemps
et d'augmenter le nombre de bras
disponibles la même manière nous
travaillons tous azimuts pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un maximum de
pharmacie sur le territoire qu'ils
puissent évidemment testé en test
antigénique mais aussi pouvoir disposer
des boîtes auto test je le dis parce que
soient les difficultés remonté par un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens depuis
quelques jours et notamment je pense à
des parents d'élèves dont les qui devait
faire tester leurs enfants ou avoir des
autotests et qui disait c'est compliqué
parfois trouver des autotests de fait
nous avons un retour qui manque environ
deux tiers des pharmacies
met à disposition des autotests qui veut
dire qu'il ya un tiers qui ne qui ne le
fait pas encore donc nous travaillons
avec les pharmaciens pour thor sens que
ce soit la totalité des pharmacies qui
demain puissent ils sautaient sinon vous
tombez sur le terme à six qui ne
redistribue pas il ya toutes les chances
pour la pharmacie qui soit à côté elle
en distribue il y avait vendredi de
mémoire 6 millions d'autos teste encore
en stock dans les officines contre 3
millions une semaine avant c'est à dire
que nous avons plutôt doubler le nombre
de d'autotest disponibles dans les
officines et d'en commander 11 millions
pour ce début de semaine qui fait qu' on
est capable de répondre à la demande
donc on continue à chaque fois de
renforcer nos capacités dépistage
maintenant je vous le dit et on peut se
le dire vu le nombre de contaminations
quotidienne qu'on enregistre le nombre
de cas contacts hors norme qu'on
enregistre il n'est pas étonnant qu'on
soit un nombre de tests réalisés
extrêmement important mais si nous
devions suivre le scénario à l'anglais
ou à l'africaine du sud et que nous
devions commencer à enregistrer une
diminution nous verrons encore une fois
suis très prudent décontamination alors
la pression petit à petit diminuera et
nous redescendrons à des niveaux de
dépistage tels que ceux que nous avons
connus c'est à dire 6 millions vous ne
posez pas de difficulté n'est pas de
files d'attentes donc je leur dis
vraiment notre à tj ne pas laisser filer
le virus ne pas paralyser le pays et
répondre à la demande
monsieur rapportant aux pays-bas le pass
vaccinale vous dites est ce que ça
s'intègre dans l'urgence sanitaire on
pourrait discuter de savoir s'il faut
attendre la loi pour mettre parfois en
place des outils qui peuvent nécessiter
mise en place urgente c'est le choix que
nous avons faits et de ne pas passer par
des arrêtés 31 31 tirs et 2 du code de
la santé publique mais de
systématiquement référé devant le
parlement à l'exception notable des
pouvoirs que vous nous avez conférer à
notre demande dans la période dite de
risque sanitaire pour pouvoir à tout
moment prendre des dispositions sans en
référer au parlement je pense à la
limitation des grands rassemblements par
exemple ou au télétravail désormais
obligatoire trois ou quatre jours par
semaine pour le reste nous avons décidé
de s'en référer au parlement ce qui
effectivement pour un petit peu plus de
temps mais néanmoins et je le dis et je
le dis en préambule monsieur le monsieur
le rapporteur
avant même que le pass vaccinale soit
adopté
les effets sont déjà visibles puisque la
simple évocation du pass vaccinale a
fait bondir le nombre de primo
vaccination dans notre pays 230 milles
pour l'essentiel plus de 200 lycées sont
des adultes je le précise parce qu'on
dit parfois c'est les enfants non pour
plus de 100000 ce sont des adultes et ça
va continuer cette semaine ça va
continuer la semaine prochaine or nous
parlons au poids de 4 millions et demi
de français à peu près qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés adultes et qui sont vaccinable
si nous avions 200 ou 300 milles par
semaine ça va vite et on arrive vite à
une couverture vaccinale plus importante
la même manière monsieur le rapporteur
il a suffi le président la république au
mois de juillet évoque le passe à lutter
pour que le soir-même souvenez-vous nous
enregistrions des bons de demandes de
rendez vous en vue d'avoir une primo
vaccination et le passé ni terre a de ce
point de vue là permis enregistré 12.7
primo vaccination de plus ce qui nous a
mis quand même dans une situation
beaucoup moins confortable que surtout
face à des vagues aussi importante que
celle ci donc le pass vaccinale est ni
la faim ni l'oméga vous avez raison
c'est une mesure supplémentaire
il vient s'ajouter et qui sera à notre
disposition si jamais si jamais il
devait y avoir de nouveaux variants
émergents nécessitant de garantir un
niveau de protection optimale et vous le
savez je le redis sa mort ça va de soi
c'est une évidence mais parfois les
évidences doit être rappelé tous ceux
qui ces outils de passes sanitaire de
passes vaccinale le jour où on en a plus
besoin le jour où nous sommes plus sous
la menace permanente d'un nouveau
variant nous en passeront avec beaucoup
de plaisir et même beaucoup de régresse
vous comme moi sur les listes des
organisations au jeu vous savez que je
ne vais pas revenir je conteste
formellement le chiffre de 20% de lits
fermés à l'hôpital et toutes les études
ont montré en revanche oui l attention à
l'hôpital et la fatigue des heures sup
qui n'ont pas été prises des démissions
qui aurait dû être prise l'année
dernière mais qui n'ont pas été prises
parce que les soignants se sont dit
c'est pas le moment de partir quand ça
tape il faut qu'on reste et on partira
plus tard vous avez des des heures
supplémentaires qui ont été accumulées
jusqu'à ce que les soignants depuis ce
plus d'accumuler parce que ça faisait
quand même beaucoup trop pour eux ils
sont extrêmement courageux d'ailleurs je
le dis parce que on parle peut-être
moins d'attention hospitalière
maintenant qu'elle est d'installer qu
avant qu'elle ne s'installe mais elle
est vive 21 mille malades dans les
hôpitaux c'est beaucoup 3800 patients
dans les réanimations pour duke au vide
c'est cette intense le nom de
déprogrammation dans notre pays a des
conséquences sur la santé des français
c'est pourquoi nous poussons vraiment à
la vaccination c'est aussi dans cet
objectif de ne pas
obérer toutes les bouches ans pour des
patients qui ne sont pas là pour le coc
vide et qui n'ont rien demandé et qui
veulent juste être soignés en temps et
en heure de pouvoir être soigné et qu'on
ne soit pas obligé de garder des places
de réanimation dans l'hypothèse où des
patients non vaccinés viendrait atteint
par le cos vide
sur le risque de désorganisation ce pour
ça j'ai encore une fois nous avons des
plans de continuité cet été a été dit
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure sur la
question spital hier de déployer des
prises en charge pré hospitalière ou
post hospitalière c'est à dire à
domicile avec de l'oxygène sommes
capables de prendre en charge jusqu'à
quinze mille patients avec de l'oxygène
à domicile nous étions montés à plus de
dix mille patients lors d'une vague
précédente je crois que c'était la
deuxième ou la troisième pardonnez moi
et donc nous étions bien en dessous là
donc on a réactivé ce réseau là pour
pouvoir libérer des lits hospitaliers
c'est fondamental sur la question des
écoles je ne parlerai pas au nom du
ministre en charge de l'éducation
nationale même si nous travaillons
évidemment main dans la main et que je
le sais très mobilisé et je le redis
dans des vagues précédentes avec ce
niveau de circulation du virus la
question de l'ouverture des écoles
auraient été posés monsieur le
rapporteur puisqu'elle a déjà eu
l'occasion de se poser est prise en la
république a souhaité sanctuariser
l'école et préserver l'éducation des
petits et je me souviens qu'à chaque
fois qu'on est en cours de vagues on
parle du problème de maintien des écoles
ouvertes à chaque fois qu'une vague est
passée on parle des conséquences sur les
enfants de des vagues et qui se sont
passées les restrictions moi je souhaite
que mon fils vraiment acté le fait que
les écoles ont vocation à rester ouvert
qu'est classes ont vocation à rester
ouvertes et que seul un dépistage assez
intensif nous permet de le faire mais ce
dépistage doit être simplifié autant que
nous le pouvons en tirant constate de ce
que nous observons et encore une fois
varions nouveau contagiosité nouvelles
données nouvelles nous faisons face en
anticipant tout ce que nous pouvons mais
aussi en étant capable de vous dire on
s'adapte parce que manifestement le
dispositif qu'on a mis en place il doit
être améliorée ou renforcés pour la
madame lalala rapporteur chantal de
seine comment résorber les inégalités
sociales et territoriales à la
vaccination je vous savez que sur tous
les territoires nous et c'est pas
nouveau gouvernement c'est nous vous les
élus locaux les associations les
médecins les pharmaciens l'extrême et
sages-femmes tout le monde mobilise
infirmiers évidemment mobilise les gens
qui ne sont pas vaccinés pour leur
expliquer il ya encore sans doute un
certain nombre de français à mon avis
peu nombreux qui sont vraiment très très
loin de tout qui sont vraiment des gens
qui sont parfois marginalisés ou qui
sont très très précarisés qui ont
assigné dans leur propre résidence et
qui effectivement nécessite qu'on aille
encore plus et des marchés chez eux mais
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui sont
informés ou désinformer et parfois un
peu plus d informer qu'un former ou qui
n'ont pas confiance certains me disent
encore je discute avec quelqu'un la
semaine dernière qui misent aimera
c'était un vaccin aux comprimés je le
prendrais
mais c'est une injection et donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on injecte quelques
quelque chose dans mon corps mais
c'était un spray nasal ou incompris mais
oui je le prendrai même site et de la rn
message est oui c'est pas pareil ça va
pas dans la circulation bas si en fait
qu'on avale un comprimé ou qu'on se le
mal qu'on les reçoive en spray au conte
les en injection in fine et ça va au
même endroit et donc il faut pas se
poser la question vous voyez il ya
parfois des résistances face auxquels on
est en butte et pia je reviens pas là
dessus sur toutes celles et ceux qui
considèrent que nous sommes des menteurs
patentés
dans une forme de délire collectif à
l'échelle planétaire et sa est coté dans
la masse et la triste si vous avez là la
solution je suis preneur en tous les cas
nous on ne s'arrête pas là c'est pas la
même vague c'est pas le même
contagiosité sur la question des masques
en extérieur et le hcsp d'ailleurs nous
avait dit en son temps qu'il considérait
que le port du masque dans les milieux
extérieur où le risque était élevé
s'avérait encore utile or nous
considérons que le risque était levé
partout à l'extérieur sauf évidemment
dans les zones désertiques ou sur les
plages du fait qu' il est très très
contagieux et donc on pense qu'on peut
se contaminer plus facilement à
l'extérieur et poser la question des
traitements qu une question fondamentale
pour vous dire qu'il ya plusieurs
médicaments qui ont vu leurs
autorisations qui étaient retirées ou
très réduite c'était très généraux et le
lilly qui sont pas des médicaments hélas
efficace sur ces nouveaux variants ça a
changé la donne et les médicaments
qu'ils étaient efficaces sur un variant
et pas forcément sur l'autre il ya ceux
de traitement très important j'avais lu
une tribune au jdd il ya dix jours de
cela l'association patients qui écrivait
d'ailleurs au président la république en
disant pour les patients immunodéprimés
aidez-nous avoir accès à un traitement
qui est à même de sauver nos vies je
leur réponds et d'ailleurs je leur
répond par écrit que le traitement dont
ils parlent qui est commercialisé par
astrazeneca qui s'appelle le traitement
aigu chez ald qui est précieux pour
protéger les populations à risque la
france a été le premier pays européen à
proposer ce traitement aux patients
concernés et le nombre de patients qui
sont actuellement en traitement par ce
médicament grâce aux dispositifs d'accès
précoce qui a mis en place au printemps
la république nous sommes à plus de 2500
patients traités il y en a mille deux
cents qui sont en cours d'inclusion et
ça monte très vite donc évidemment c'est
j'ai été très sensible à cette tribune
parce que je me mets à la place de
famille ou de patients souffrant
d'immunodépression
qui entendent qu'on ne parle on parle
beaucoup de noms vacciner et de vacciner
consiste comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure
en introduction les gens immunodéprimés
qui sont à risque ils disent mettez nous
on n'a pas envie d'être les victimes
collatérales de tout ça il faut il faut
nous aider et donc vraiment je le redis
que l'engagement de la france et total à
leurs côtés et pour s'en convaincre je
le redis l'offre la france et à date le
seul pays européen toujours à proposer
ce traitement prophylactique aux
patients
la france ne dispose plus à ce jour
d'alternative curative efficace à face
aux variants omicron mais nous attendons
d'eux déploiement d'ici la fin de ce
mois pour lesquelles nous sommes très
bien positionnés pour être parmi les
premiers si ce n'est les premiers à
recevoir ces médicaments c'est le pacs
le vide de pfizer est un traitement par
voie orale
et le saute robbie mahb le médicament
gsk qui sera administré à l'hôpital il
ya d'autres médicaments qui en reste
encore à venir qui sont en cours de
développement mais pose des questions
sur l'inspection du travail a lorsqu'il
avait deux bornes vous répondrait bien
mieux que moi mais je me risque sous
coûts sous contrôle des juristes qui
m'encadrent à vous dire que on doit pas
avoir une grille d'analysé différentes
de l'échelle des sanctions en fait
aujourd'hui on est dans un régime pénal
et on va passer dans un régime
administratif pour rendre la mesure plus
opérantes mais ça ne change pas l'esprit
nous allons prendre six
collègues ensuite ne reprend une
nouvelle vague de subir de deux
questions bernard jomier
merci madame est à présent plus
seulement réservé aux seuls ministres
trois courtes question la première
lorsque nous avons auditionné dans la
même configuration au mois de début
novembre vous nous aviez déjà dit que le
nombre de primo vacciner augmenter
fortement ces v6 tsi 40 à 50 me ce qui
n'était pas le cas mais là cette fois ci
vous avez raison
effectivement le nombre de primo
vaccinées augmente fortement et la
différence c'est que l'obligation est
arrivé dans vos propos même si c'est
sous forme déguisée ce que je regrette
les ministres n'ont pas à déguiser leur
décision mais enfin le terme est apparu
vous avez raison aussi de rappeler que
la parole du chef de l'état entraîne des
changements d'attitude chez français
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas ce
temps perdu et ce qui n'est pas le temps
d'être franc direct et de poser le
principe de l'obligation vaccinale qui
s'ils ne convaincra jamais la petite
minorité d'anti vague fait qu'un certain
nombre de français du coup franchissent
le pas ils seront vaccinés deuxième
question vous avez rappelé que les
patients qui sont en réanimation qui
sont vaccinés sont très largement des
patients immunodéprimés il ne bénéficie
pas de la prise en charge masques ffp2
alors qu'il mérite la protection la
meilleure contre la diffusion du vaccin
et que par exemple les patients ld
simple bénéficient de la prise en charge
du remboursement des masques dits
chirurgicaux
est ce que vous comptez proposer ou à
ses patients particulièrement fragiles
qui sont quelques centaines de milliers
dans notre pays et qui sont vaccinées
des masques ffp2 troisièmement et
dernière question un membre du conseil
scientifique a exprimé ce matin je vais
citer sa phrase directement il a dit la
stratégie de laisser circuler sans
contrôler le virus est une erreur
fondamentale c'est exactement ce qui est
fait dans les écoles au mois de novembre
alors que le nombre de classes fermées
augmenter le ministre de l'éducation a
même un temps allégé le protocole quand
appliquerez vous dans les écoles une
stratégie claire de réduction de la
circulation du virus au lieu du chaos
qui règne actuellement
alors il y un assassinat christine
bonfanti-dossat loïc hervé florence
lassarade esther benbassa damas merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
président madame et messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le
g2 question puisque effectivement nous
aurons longas l'occasion de débattre
plus longuement lors de notre séance
demain et après demain donc bien
évidemment lutter contre l'épidémie
suppose de prendre des mesures notamment
d'appeler d'inciter nos compatriotes à
la vaccination ce que nous partageons
bien évidemment et vous avez pris un
exemple dans vos propos monsieur le
ministre très démonstratif d'un monsieur
qui n'est pas anti bac je suis là qui
n'est pas anti vague mais qui
préférerait avoir autre chose qu'une
piqûre pour se faire vacciner donc il ya
encore matière à faire de la pédagogie
et à convaincre en revanche nous ne
sommes pas favorables donc à la
contrainte et je voulais déjà dit j'ai
conscience que et nous avons conscience
que le pass sanitaire a convaincu des
milliers de nos concitoyennes et donc
aux citoyens à se faire vacciner en
revanche force est de constater que cela
n'a pas empêché la prog la propagation
du virus même si aujourd'hui le variant
au micro et moins dangereux que est
moins dangereux oui que le variant delta
même si au bicross est très très très
contagieux donc ce tout ça nous
interroge sur votre choix de passer du
passage du ter au pass maximale dont
l'application entre autres entraves et
les libertés et en la matière la
sémantique et quelquefois très magique
deuxième qui essaient première question
donc le seul ministre avez vous un bilan
précis de l'usaj du pass sanitaires et
deuxième question mais vous avez
l'habitude parce que j'ai l'occasion de
la pose et à chaque fois que j'en ai
l'occasion
mais qui restent sans réponse donc je la
repose aujourd'hui car nous sommes
content qu'on confronté à une pandémie
et donc à une question mondiale or seuls
50 % de la population mondiale est
vacciné ne serait-il pas temps monsieur
le ministre que les 50 % de la
population mondiale qui n'est pas
vacciné et les états puissent avoir
accès aux preuves au brevet pour avoir
le droit de se faire vacciner merci
christine bonfanti de sang merci madame
la présidente de ce ministre l'année
2022 s'annonce aussi compliquée que 2021
parce que nous ne verrons probablement
pas le bout de la crise sanitaire sauf à
en croire l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui s'interroge sérieusement sur
la stratégie qui consiste à accélérer la
vaccination dans les pays riches ce que
vous êtes en train de faire monsieur le
ministre alors qu'il faudrait prioriser
les pays pauvres où une très grande
majorité de la population n'a pas reçu
la première dose il faudrait toujours
d'après l'organisation mondiale de la
santé si l'on veut reprendre le contrôle
de cette pandémie que 70% de la
population de chaque pays soient
vaccinés dans les six mois
alors que le président de la république
règle ses comptes à ok qu'ovide avec les
non vaccinés
alors que le premier ministre parle déjà
de quatrième dose de plus en plus de
personnes dont je suis monsieur le
ministre s'interroge et doutes sur
l'efficacité sanitaire du pacte
d'actionnaires monsieur le ministre ne
pensez vous pas que le plus urgent
aujourd'hui au lieu de vouloir accélérer
la vaccination comme vous le faite de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour vacciner le
monde entier
loïc hervé ensuite ce sera florence
lassarade
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre j'aurais aimé vous interroger
sur le protocole appliqua dans les
écoles et la désorganisation massive que
nous connaissons tous les jours ci dans
l'éducation nationale j'aurais aussi
aimé vous interroger sur les
conséquences économiques des
modifications des règles du pass
sanitaire en france sur le tourisme à
l'égard la clientèle étrangère dans la
perspective des vacances de février mais
j'y reviendrai en séance monsieur le
ministre au micro déferle sur la france
et chaque jour des centaines de millions
de français vaccinés ou non sont
contaminés vacciner triple dose j'en ai
fait moi même l'expérience la semaine
dernière mes chers collègues nous en
sommes tous témoins dans notre entourage
tous témoins de ce qui se passe dans
notre pays à elle seule cette réalité
aurait dû nous démontrer l'inutilité
sanitaires d'une grande partie des
mesures privatives de liberté au premier
rang desquels le pass sanitaires mais
tel un mantra vous continuer de répéter
que l'objectif du passe aujourd'hui
sanitaire demain vaccinale est de créer
des lieux sans contagiosité devant la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale vous avez déclaré je vous cite
on va continuer de resserrer les mailles
pour pouvoir garantir non seulement que
les endroits recevant du public sont
indemnes de gens potentiellement
contagieux à mes yeux le moment est
évidemment venu de lever la plupart des
restrictions aux libertés publiques et
non les renforcer c'est pourquoi j'ai
déposé un amendement à l'article 1er qui
propose non seulement de renoncer au
pass vaccinale mais de supprimer
purement et simplement le passé l'état
dans notre pays monsieur le ministre
pouvait vous devant la commission des
lois composé de gens sérieux et
rationnel revenir sur cette affirmation
selon laquelle le pass protégerait de la
contamination et à défaut de le faire
devant la cnil qui vous a demandé
moult reprises pour vous transmettre au
parlement des éléments objectifs et
chiffré qui étaient vos affirmations je
vous remercie
laurence arabe ça intéresse aussi la
commission des affaires sociales merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je suis d'abord là pour relayer
l'inquiétude est là l'épuisement des
soignants libéraux cette fois ci il n'y
a pas que les hôpitaux des infirmiers
font des autotests actuellement et on me
montre quand même particulièrement que
le prix du matériel à quadruples est
quasiment 2 en particulier les gants
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
donner une aide sur ce secteur là je
vais pas revenir sur le test et la
désorganisation en particulier quand ya
contradiction entre auto test test pcr
et est antigénique skis et ski et leur
pain quotidien
je voudrais vous poser des questions
précises sur le sur l'anticipation par
l'utilisation des de la détection dans
les écoutes ministre
l'anticipation dans la détection dans
les stations d'épuration et les égouts
qui permet qui a permis avec le réseau b
pin de détecter à peu près 15 jours à
l'avance les vagues successives et de
les affiner selon les endroits où est-ce
qu'on en est de ces de ses
préconisations et est ce que vous
comptez sur cette utilisation
deuxièmement on a également beaucoup
parlé des capteurs de co2 des
purificateurs d'air
qui apporterait en particulier des
endroits qu'on a du mal à ventiler
apporterait un vraiment plus et il ya
des pays qui se sont massivement mis à
les utiliser puisque finalement
l'endroit où on se contaminent à l'heure
actuelle c'est l'école
là où là où il n'y a pas de vaccin ou
peu de vaccins je m'arrête là ce qui est
encore certainement beaucoup de
questions
esther benbassa
merci de me donner la parole d'abord je
dirais que je suis triple vacciner et
j'étais aussi malade du coc vite donc je
ne suis pas anti vax
voilà est d'abord je voudrais vous
demander s'il y a vraiment une nécessité
de une chance pour passer du pass anita
au passé vaccinale et nous n'avons
aucune donnée sur l'efficacité du code
sanitaire ni des données sur le pass
vaccinale ok le conseil constitutionnel
doit vérifier la nécessité et la
proportionnalité de ce texte ensuite je
me pose la question sur
l'instrumentalisation de la parole
médical qui creuse cette panique et qui
permet également un directement et
indirectement à tainmont superflu 2 de
restreindre nos libertés
alors c'est un ciment talent isation est
assez étonnant parce que
la question des hôpitaux plein le manque
de personnel ce ne sont pas des
questions nouvelles ce discours
médicalisé ne fait que cacher la réalité
depuis enfin avant même l'arrivée de
monsieur macro et de son gouvernement au
pouvoir et les hôpitaux poser des vraies
questions de ge et de mauvaise gestion
de la santé alors
il faut prendre d'autres mesures aussi
arrêter les tests pour les gens sans
symptôme se sert à rien essayez de deux
de ne pas créer cette stigmatisation
d'une partie de la population qui ne
veut pas se vacciner ceux qui auraient
été réglés par un vaccin obligatoire par
une vaccination obligatoire et et nous
sommes là dans une sorte de crise
on ne guérit pas c'est vrai qu'il ya une
personne sur quatre qui est contaminée
parmi les triple vacciner donc il
faudrait peut-être
essayer de 2 de prendre d'autres mesures
et elles ont forcé les barrières
essayer de convaincre davantage surtout
en zone rurale fr avoir des référents
qui vont dans les chais les gens pour
les combats n'y est arrêté ces mesures
qui se multiplient pour ne pas va faire
un vaccin une vaccination obligatoire
merci
monsieur le ministre je voulais répondre
cette première série de questions
volontiers vous ai parlé d' obligation
vaccinale déguisé dans une dans une
interview ça m'a été rappelé en quelques
occasions c'est cet argent mais je sais
pas si c'est une obligation vaccinale
déguisé en tout cas c'est une
formule qui me paraît mais je peux me
tromper plus efficace qu'une obligation
vaccinale ce qui te sens oui sauf à me
démontrer que vous êtes capables
d'identifier parce que qui dit
obligation dit contrôler 10 qui dit
contrôler les sanctions si vous
identifier un niveau de sanction
qui est susceptible de faire basculer
quelqu'un qui considère que le vac avec
le vaccin vous voulez lui est inoculé je
ne sais quel poison
est le ba oui monsieur le sénateur il
vient d'un des anti pacs et irna c'est
pas une minorité de gens parmi ce que
recherche vacciner non attendez il ya
des gens qui dit que c'était obligatoire
il le ferait mais vous savez il ya
beaucoup de gens aussi qui considérait
que s'il ne pouvais plus aller aux bars
et restaurants sauf à être vaccinés ils
seraient vaccinés d'ailleurs ça tombe
bien puisqu'il ils le font un max frisch
je pars entraînera dialogue au sein de
la commission mais avec avec plaisir
l'extérieur si vous le souhaitez
si vous voulez le il ya une
recommandation très claire pour le port
de masques ffp2 pour les personnes qui
souffrent d'immunodépression aux
pathologies d'ailleurs qui donne lieu à
un remboursement dans un certain nombre
de situations je vais évidemment à ce
que personne ne soit privé de masques
ffp2 pour des questions de coûts dès
lors qu'ils se verraient prescrire ces
masques
le cas dans un grand nombre de personnes
immunodéprimées dans notre pays
d'ailleurs avec ou sans que coronavirus
il faut le savoir j'ai eu plusieurs
questions sur la question sur le sur le
sujet des écoles je le redis un
notre notre objectif c'est de réduire la
circulation du virus dans les écoles est
de maintenir les écoles ouvertes il faut
donc avec ces deux principes que nous
trublion le dispositif qui soit le plus
à même de lui permettre de garder un
oeil actifs sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie chez les enfants et en même
temps de ne pas rendre les choses
inopérante ou trop compliqué pour les
parents j'ai entendu notamment nous
avons entendu qu'un certain nombre de
parents se sont trouvés en difficulté
lorsqu'ils apprenaient la veille au soir
qu'un enfant dans l'orne dans la classe
de leur enfant allait être contaminées
pour se trouver un test à j0 qui sont un
test antigénique au pcr ça peut être
compliqué quand vous êtes dans une
période de vastes circulation de virus
et que accéder à la pharmacie peut-être
compliqué peut supposer peut se poser
peut-être la question je ne fais pas ici
d'un outil de réponse un travail
interministériel qui doivent conduire
mais de savoir si on peut faciliter
peut-être l'accès aux auto test dès le
premier test qui serait peut être de
nature à je dirais simplifier la vie
d'enfants de parents nous allons voir
encore une fois cela je le dis en toute
en toute simplicité à chaque fois que
nous voyons qu'un protocole doit être
réajusté pour le rendre encore plus
opérationnel et vivable pour les
français nous le faisons et nous le
ferons dans la durée
je ne j'ai répondu sur cette question
sur les doses les dons doses aux pays
pauvres d'abord la france est le premier
est l'un des premiers contributeurs au
monde et c'est à la demande du président
la république c'est factuel c'est dans
les tablettes pouvez regarder que a été
monté un dispositif très tôt de dons de
pays des pays les plus usées vers les
pays les plus en difficultés pour
accéder aux contrats tout le monde n'a
pas la chance de faire partie l'union
européenne et d'avoir un accès à des
commandes massif auprès des laboratoires
au moins chaque français a donné au mois
déjà une dose à un pays pauvre et ce
sera bientôt deux doses par français
donnés à des pays pauvres ça n'est pas
incompatible de vacciner les français de
vacciner le monde et c'est une nécessité
que de continuer de renforcer la
politique vaccinale notamment à
destination des pays les plus pauvres
parce que c'est une protection pour eux
mais c'est aussi protection pour nous
puisque plus vite la planète sera
vacciné plus nous aurons de chances de
ne pas voir apparaître de nouveaux
variants dangereux donc je n'oppose pas
les deux
et la question qui était posée par le
sénateur loïc hervé équidés vous êtes
dans une continuité vis-à-vis du pass
sanitaires et et dubé donc évidemment du
pass vaccinale dans nos positions ce que
j'entends bien d'abord vous rappeler que
le conseil d'état l'a validé que le
conseil scientifique l'appelle de ses
voeux et le conte et le pass sanitaires
et maintenant le pass vaccinale que
certains pays ont fait le choix d'aller
plus loin c'est notamment le pass deux
gpus en allemagne c'est un pass
vaccinale plus sanitaire cd il faut être
totalement vacciner et présenter un test
moi j'ai envie de vous prendre le
raisonnement inverse monsieur le
sénateur vous dites moi j'ai un
amendement qui supprime le pass et qui
supprime ces mesures dans l'est dans les
endroits dans lesquels le pass
s'applique ça veut dire que vous êtes en
train d'expliquer avec notre amendement
s'il était adopté que demain alors que
nous sommes à 300 milles contamination
par jour on pourrait aller au restaurant
ou dans les bars on pourrait se
rassembler en milieu clos manger chanter
rire danser en étant ni vacciné ni
tester
les supprimer le pad sanitaire en l'état
avec un amendement qui supprime ces
mesures là ça ça veut dire ça t elle
demain on dit aux français en fait alesi
et puis advienne que pouvoir on le
devine que pourra il ya très peu de pays
qui ont essayé au monde généralement ils
ont changé de cap assez vite quand il
s'est rendu compte que les vagues
étaient trop hautes et l'impact
sanitaire trop importants dans leur pays
la question sur les eaux usées en fait
on continue de travailler avec beaucoup
de stations et le réseau aubépines la
sénatrice il y a des moments il ya des
stations où on a des données qui étaient
plus ou moins conformes à l'attendu des
endroits où c'était encore je dirais à
conforter d'un point de vue scientifique
et notamment on l'avait vu l'hiver
dernier que la montée des eaux que
l'hydre attaque le les pluies que la
fonte des neiges emporté des
conséquences puisqu'il avait entraîné
des dilutions plus importante des traces
de virus dans les eaux usées et dont il
n'y avait pas une règle très clair qui
permettait d'avoir de définir quels
étaient niveau précis de circulation
d'épidémie sage chercher cela étant que
manger dans toutes lés toutes les
semaines dans mes dossiers j'ai cette
question des des traces de virus dans
les eaux usées qu'on regarde avec
intérêt notamment plutôt dans les
périodes où ça circule beaucoup moins
pour voir s'il ya des signes précoces de
ré émergence là la situation actuelle
fait que vous cherchez des traces des
virus dans les eaux usées vous allez
retrouver puisqu'il y en a absolument
partout
pour madame la sénatrice benbassa c'est
un peu dans la même logique quand vous
dites vous dites on instrumentalise la
parole médical et juste après on fait
une affirmation que je ne me permettrais
pas de faire ni comme médecin il comme
ministre je dis ça mais vous n'êtes dire
je vous cite on devrait arrêter ce
tester les gens sans symptôme parce que
ça ne sert à rien mais moi je ne sais
pas madame la sénatrice ça sert à rien
je crois plutôt que ça ne sert pas à
rien j'ai même quasiment convaincu du
contraire 1 vous pouvez ne pas avoir de
symptômes et parfaitement contagieuse
et donc si vous ne restez pas les gens
qui sont qu'à contacter par exemple qui
sont à risque d'être contaminé de ne pas
le savoir parce qu'ils sont vaccinés
mais qui peuvent quand même transmettre
le virus vous risquez d'avoir une
diffusion du virus encore plus
importante
donc on peut pas dire des choses comme
celles fille voyez pas ce que on donne
un pressentiment en français qu'en fait
tu aurais d'aider des questions qui
donnerait lieu à interprétation
factuellement je ne sais plus haute est
que l'on trouve plus on trouve plus on
préserve ceux qui ne sont pas cons ceux
qui ne sont pas encore touchés et plus
on amoindri l'ampleur d'une vague
épidémique donc réjouissons-nous
l'attraper kit est beaucoup et
réjouissons-nous d'être peut-être
bientôt un pays qui testera un peu moins
vrai qu'il y aura moins de cas positifs
parce que la vague sera passé
et enfin tu devais faire une analogie
j'aime pas trop mais ben ben bassat je
dirai pas ce que vous dites le vaccin
finalement ils ont peut être on peut
être à j'ai eu 3 d'eau j'ai eu le virus
etc voyez dans ce cas là le si vous le
souhaitez le vaccin comme un double
airbag
2 airbags dans votre voiture il vous
empêchera pas d'avoir un accident de
voiture si vous vous devez rentrer en
collision avec un autre véhicule donc
j'ai un double airbag mais génial
accident ouais mais j'ai un double
airbags dont tu as eu la vie sauve
non mais je ne dis pas un outil pas vous
avez dit le contraire je vous propose
dans le prolongement de la discussion
cette analogie j'ai un double airbag
j'ai eu la vie sauve j'avais pas double
airbag la baisse de mortalité routière
l'une des principales mesures qui a fait
baisser la mortalité routière notre pays
c'est la sécurisation de véhicules et
donc on apporte de plus en plus de
sécurité et ça permet deux mais c'est
pas parce que vous avez double airbag
que vous allez rouler à 170 sinon le
risque d'avoir un accident il sera
encore très important voyez j'arrête là
l'analogie mais c'était vraiment pourra
essayer de visualiser les choses
merci monsieur munitions de continuer à
essayer des questions encore beaucoup de
monde madame valérie boyer puis madame
laurence cohen ensuite monsieur alain
richard monsieur olivier henno monsieur
jean yves le conte et madame laurent
pignol madame boyer merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre avant de
commencer mon propos je
permettez moi de vous faire part de mon
émotion face aux propos du président de
la république je crois ici que nous
sommes dans une assemblée sérieuse et
que de façon quasi unanime nous sommes
pour le vaccin l'obligation est un autre
débat et nous l'avons eue ici d'ailleurs
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
passer à autre chose bien sûr vous aurez
toujours des français qui sont opposés à
la vaccination et ce débat est loin
d'être nouveau à titre personnel je le
regrette mais je le répète depuis le
début je ne crois pas à la contrainte et
encore moins à la vulgarité et surtout a
demandé à la représentation nationale de
faire des choses qui ne sont pas pour le
bien des français mais pour les embêter
pour ne pas employer ces termes
il est de votre responsabilité
d'expliquer aux français en quoi votre
stratégie serait la bonne et surtout de
faire preuve de cohérence nous le savons
désormais le bac ça n'empêche pas le
virus de circuler il a des effets
positifs bien sûr mais des français
veulent savoir en quoi le pass vaccinale
peut limiter la propagation du virus
pourquoi vacciner des personnes qui ont
un taux d'anticorps élevé est-ce que
vous pouvez répondre à cette question
concernant le pass
jeu peut-être allez-vous répondre qu'il
permet d'éviter la cites la saturation
encore des services de réanimation
dans ce cas pourquoi avoir poursuivi la
fermeture de lits de réanimation le
nombre de 5700 suppressions de lits a
été évoquée je voudrais savoir ce qu'il
en est de façon précise
pourquoi dans ce cas ne pas avoir ouvert
des ré a particulièrement mobile ou
temporaire comme cela a été suggéré est
ce le manque de personnel et pourquoi
avoir mis à pied du personnel non
vaccinés
pourquoi ne pas faire peser faire faire
peser des risques aux malades et dans ce
cas pourquoi autoriser désormais le
personnel positive au co vide à
travailler mais pas le personnel non
vaccinés à moins que ce soient des
fausses informations et dans ce cas
j'aimerais bien avoir la réponse alors
nous le savons tous il y à une élection
présidentielle dans moins 90 jours
qui pourrait nous enfermer dans des
postures mais je crois que rien ne
justifie l'insulté et l'invectivé et
c'est une pas ça qui va rassurer les
gens pour qu'ils puissent être vacciné
je dirais bien au contraire ça risque de
les braquer et rien ne justifie non plus
les menaces répétées du gouvernement en
cherchant à stigmatiser une partie des
français considérés comme des sous
citoyens aussi une manière solennelle
monsieur le ministre je voudrais que
vous puissiez rassurer les français
apaiser notre nation et maintenir la
cohésion nationale et enfin j'aurai une
dernière remarque à faire je voudrais
saluer ici concernant les eaux usées
comme l'a souligné notre collègue le
magnifique travail réalisé par les
marins pompiers de marseille qui permet
effectivement même si c'est pas un outil
parfait mais de suivre pour cette
épidémie comme pour d'autres à l'avenir
l'évolution de des maladies en tout cas
c'est un c'est un travail d'une grande
qualité que nous ne pouvons que saluer
je vous remercie merci laurence cohen ou
non pas chacun des tasses et conscience
que nous avons encore une quinzaine de
questions merci madame la présidente
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
propos vos propos introductif vous avez
noté à juste titre l'engagement des
personnels soignants et des personnels
d'une manière générale
à la fois du secteur de la santé mais du
secteur aussi médicaux médico social
mais en même temps ils sont au bord de
l'épuisement vous l'avez dit aussi et
les conditions de travail ne cesse de se
dégrader alors vous allez me répondre
oui milieu ségur mais on voit on sait on
rencontre parce qu'il ya des auditions
ce moment il ya une commission d'
enquête sur la situation des hôpitaux et
les personnels toutes catégories
confondues nous disent que ça n'est plus
possible que les conditions sont
extrêmement difficile et qu'il faudrait
embaucher du personnel et pour ça il
faut modifier les conditions de travail
donc ma question est simple
quelle mesure vous allez prendre pour
justement faire face à ce manque de
personnel comment vous allez rendre plus
attractif ces professions ça veut dire
donc en améliorant les conditions de
travail et c'est pas seulement des
augmentations salariales ça va plus loin
et quel plan de formation massif vous
avez l'intention de être en place parce
qu'il faut le faire dès aujourd'hui si
on veut arrêter donc cette hémorragie
parce que ils partent comme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs dit sur la pointe des pieds
ou avec fracas tellement la situation
est difficile et ma deuxième question
plus courte c'est sur l'article 1 vous
avez décidé de prolonger les dispositifs
d'accompagnement des médecins du secteur
privé victime de déprogrammation
répétées de soins non urgents je crois
jusqu'au 30 juin de 2022 ma question est
simple c'est pourquoi vous n'avez pas
étendu cette mesures ou au secteur
public
et j'aimerais effectivement que vous
puissiez nous apporter une réponse parce
que contenu de l'article 40 ça ne pourra
pas faire de notre part obligatoirement
l'objet d'un des moments où ça sera
assez difficile vous remercie
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure vous
avez mentionné
une propension la transmission du virus
qui serait diminuée je crois qu'être
terme était de moitié
dans le cas de deux vaccinations
et j'aimerais savoir
comment ce s'expriment les différentes
composantes de la communauté
scientifique sur ce sujet cas il m'a
semblé qu'il était encore assez discuté
et qui avaient des hypothèses assez
opposées qui
s'opposent qui ce qui se présentait la
seconde question c'est que vous avez
mentionné le très beau et fort qui est
fait dans les eaux pharmaceutiques pour
la diffusion des tests et notamment des
autotests
vous avez jugé nécessaire et je partage
cette appréciation de faire diffuser
également les autotests par le réseau de
la grande distribution
seulement pour un mois pour des raisons
d'équilibré économique on comprend bien
mais est-ce que à l'heure actuelle vous
voyez
une réponse effective de la grande
distribution à ceux à cette mission
parce qu'il semble pliée au contraire
beaucoup de phénomènes de saturation et
de déficit de l'ivresse de livraison
dans la grande distribution enfin
puisque vous évoquiez le système kovacs
est-ce qu'il est partagé par d'autres
puissances eux
développé et est ce qu on lutte en route
vers un niveau de l'accident sion dans
l'année qui vient significative des pays
en développement
olivier neau oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre moi j'ai
voté le pass sanitaire je vois très
probablement le passo vaccinale est
pourtant voyez vous j'ai un doute plus
important sur la pertinence de la mesure
et sur son efficacité
pourquoi parce que au fond ça change
pour qui ce passe vaccinale pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés et
préféré se faire tester à leurs frais et
qui bénéficié de ce pass
sanitaires ils sont à mon sens assez peu
nombreux sans doute à avoir utilisé ces
tests payant est ce que d'ailleurs d'un
certain point de vue en un certain
nombre de statistiques sur ces questions
donc texte utile ou textes de
communication voilà la question que je
me posais et celle ci est maintenant sur
les vaccins une question un peu voisine
de de celle du sénateur richard
de monsieur le ministre
quand même les anti vaccins sont le
procès de la dangerosité du vaccin on
pourrait aussi quand même faire le
procès de leur relative inefficacité moi
dans ma famille tout le monde a fait
trois doses respecter les gestes
barrière être prudents en brasse plus on
sert plus la main tout le monde a eu
copie de ces temps derniers sans
exception pratiquement et monfils et
jambon c'est bien je jamais mais quand
même je n'en mets ma question n'est pas
celle là mc ma question est la suivante
est ce que vous vous voyez avec la
commande la communauté scientifique un
horizon pour des vaccins il s'agit pas
de les remettre en cause mais des ave
des vaccins plus efficaces qui
permettrait d'en finir avec cette
maladie et de renforcer encore leamy
noter que l'immunité collective est ce
qu'il ya une ou un horizon sur sur cette
question de l'amélioration encore de
l'efficacité des vaccins je vous
remercie
monsieur le comte jeudi à chacun d'entre
nous surtout me pose la question
une prise de parole une question mercy
jamais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
trois courtes question la première qu en
est il des personnes qui ont des contre
indications médicales aux vaccins
seront elles privées par construction du
pass de du pass vaccinale ou d'un
équivalent monsieur le fur a posé la
question à l'assemblée nationale de
semble-t-il sans réponse précise
deuxième question monsieur le ministre
vous pouvez vous prendre l'engagement
monsieur vous pouvez vous prendre
l'engagement que les personnes qui ont
eu des débuts ont des parcours vaccinale
à l'étranger pourront
obtenir un pass vaccinale alors qu'on
sait que au delà de la reconnaissance
des vaccins maintenant il ya des
philosophies différentes d'un pays à
l'autre en matière de troisième dose est
ce que vous pouvez prendre l'engagement
qu'il y aura un arrêté ou un décret qui
dira comment quel que soit le début de
parcours vaccinale on pourra avoir accès
à un pass vaccinale en france enfin
troisième question dans l'article 2 du
projet de loi on prévoit de donner les
informations relatives qui sont contenus
dans dans six départs matière de
résultats des tests aux services
préfectoraux pouvez vous nous dire
exactement ce qu'il en est et à quel
usage est ce qu'il s'agit de transmettre
l'ensemble des informations ou
simplement d information qui permettrait
de libérer de quarantaine des personnes
qui ont eu des tests négatifs je vous
remercie
laurence rossignol
donc j'ai une question la première est
assez simple dans la loi du 5 août on
avait prévu par l'amendement mais la
deuxième ne seront aussi ouverts et
monsieur le ministre
on avait prévu par l'amendement que pour
la vaccination des enfants
l'autorisation parentale d'un seul des
deux parents su s'il suffisait j'ai une
petite j'ai un petit doute sur le texte
tel qu'il sorte de l'assemblée nationale
est ce que cette
facilité est reprise est-ce qu'elle
s'applique deux ans de par conséquence
ou est-ce qui va s que nous avons la
mission de d'amender le texte visant de
l'assemblée pour reprendre la règle de
deux buts la loi du 5 août
bon une fois que vous aurez à prendre ma
deuxième question c'est que vous savez
vous mener plusieurs débats au parlement
avec les différentes sensibilités du
parlement vous savez que celui que vous
menez avec nous les socialistes n'est
pas un débat sur l' oblique sur le
vaccin c'est un débat sur l'obligation
vaccinale l'efficacité en termes de
santé publique de l'obligation vaccinale
comparée à celle d'abord du pass
sanitaires et maintenant du pass
vaccinale ma question est simple plus
comme ennemi mais madame et monsieur le
président nous nous presse est ce que
vous serez en séance demain après demain
pour qu'on puisse avoir ce débat avec
vous
[Applaudissements]
allez on continue décidé questions
courtes on va aller vite mangas tels
malheurs
bagatelle merci monsieur le président
mais un président de monsieur le
ministre j'ai propre petite question
très courte
l'ouverture de l'école c'est une très
bonne chose mais on sait qu'on gagne la
guerre grâce à l'intendance or
aujourd'hui c'est fort compliquée pour
les familles de pouvoir tester leurs
enfants jusqu'à trois fois par semaine
et les petits enfants ont beaucoup de
mal avec certains tests pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous devrons pas davantage
au test salivaire il semblerait qu'au
micro et puisque le permettent
deuxièmement j'ai une question sur les
faux pas de sanitaires est ce qu'on sait
le nombre de faux pas sanitaire qu'il y
a est-ce que vous pensez que les
dispositifs que vous proposez de
repentance en quelque sorte encouragera
les gens à se faire vacciner
troisième question pour l'avenir
quid des personnes qui sont victimes de
kovy de long et qui voit à la fois leur
vie professionnelle mais aussi leur vie
personnelle et sociale totalement
bouleversé est ce que vous avez eu le
temps pensez peut-être pas encore mais
certainement un jour vous poserez vous
la question monsieur mini de pouvoir
leur octroyer le bénéfice des
dispositions ld merci monsieur le
ministre victor
madame la présidente monsieur président
monsieur ministres au mois de juillet
dernier j'évoquais déjà les difficultés
concernant l'efficacité des vaccins que
vous proposiez j'avais même dit qu'il y
avait une
difficulté avec la cinétique nationale
et la réponse immunitaire et on passait
à ce moment-là à une éventuelle
troisième dole maintenant parler de
quatrième dose la presse que le disait
monsieur d être ici il n'y a pas bien
longtemps donc on s'interroge vraiment
son efficacité ça a déjà été dit par
certains de mes collègues d'autre part
le vaccin que vous proposez n'empêche
pas n'est pas n'empêche pas la
contamination n'empêche pas d'être
malade enfin bon c'est en fait une
prévision une prévention ne dirai et la
difficulté qui se pose aujourd'hui dans
certains de nos hôpitaux c'est que des
professionnels qui pourraient peut-être
travailler tout simple mais qui pourrait
justifier avec un pass vaccinale de la
négativité de leur théologie et bien
aujourd'hui sont suspendus alors qu'est
ce que vous proposez est ce que ce
serait pas pertinent là où en tout cas
ce serait nécessaire parce qu'il ya
également la couverture par rapport aux
soins qui pond qui seront en danger pour
les patients qui sont en danger parce
qu'il faut savoir également que il ya
deux ans au moment du plfss nous avions
cessé nos travaux justement parce que
dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux beaucoup de
soignants et ses regrets pour les moyens
particulièrement les moyens humains
aujourd'hui en suspendant ces
professionnels qui sont diplômés qui
savent de quoi il s'agit donc ce sont
des personnes qui connaissent vraiment
ce que c'est et pourquoi ils ont fait le
choix ne pas se faire vacciner pour le
moment eh bien on se passe de ces
personnes là quel prix à quel prix alors
aujourd'hui joe cocker vous demande
vraiment est-ce que entre ces personnes
qui ne sont probablement pas vaccinés
qui devrait peut-être le faire la cae le
voir mais et les personnes qui sont
vaccinées qui sont malades quelle serait
la différence par rapport aux soins
qu'il pourrait apporter dans certains de
nos établissements
merci on va prendre toutes les questions
parce qu'il ya souvent des réponses
communes à des questions qui parfois
sont très proches les unes des autres
catherine du folk oh
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je vais revenir sur le sujet
déjà abordé par madame cohen concernant
les hôpitaux et puis le compléter
peut-être donc cette pandémie a révélé
en réalité le malaise qui existe dans
nos services hospitaliers nous pouvons
effectivement salué le travail
considérable qui est réalisé par par les
personnels les remercie pour leur
engagement à tous les niveaux je suis là
si on ne cherchait c'est ça voilà
voilà donc j'ai dix les remercie
effectivement tout le tout le personnel
pour le niveau d'engagement sur tous les
postes et puis comprendre leur état de
fatigue au terme de ces deux années très
difficiles tous les jours nous entendons
des informations qui sont alarmantes sur
les activités des services d'urgence et
de réanimation parle beaucoup de
déprogrammation d'opération je voudrais
savoir ce qu'il en est de la prise en
charge par les établissements
hospitaliers privés dans cette pandémie
dans la prise en charge des patients
atteints de vide sont ils réellement
sollicité pour venir en aide aux
hôpitaux publics merci monsieur guy
laroche qui est en visio
en une minute c'est la première en une
minute le vous avez dit que le premier
texte il était question de loi d'urgence
pour aux seules femmes lutter contre la
propagation d'épidémies vous parlez plus
de lutter contre la propagation dans
cette fois vous avez supprimé faire de
propagation est-ce que vous assumez donc
votre politique que vous pourriez tout à
fait assumée qui est d'abandonner la
lutte contre la propagation et d'avoir
laissé ce virus pour les réseaux que
nous on n'a pas discuté se répandre
deuxième question vous parlait d'aller
vers la population marginale et vous
dites que c'est que des neuf accidents
et sociales beau réfractaires l'étude de
lycées de l'inserm qui a été mené sur un
petit échantillon monte qui à 40% leurs
habitants que ce soit un peu moins de
gens qui en fait principalement des
difficultés d'accès à la vaccination
comme les immigrés les personnes âgées
ou du fait qu'ils soient isolés
socialement la troisième je vous avais
interrogé avant la troisième dose en
vous demandant quelles étaient vos
attentions en séance du sénat et j'avais
pas eu de réponse alors que juste après
vous avez intégré la troisième dose dans
le passo sanitaire ma question est
quelles sont vos intentions sur la
quatrième dose savez vous quel type de
quatrième dose vous allez mettre à
disposition corp et pour qui
et je terminerai en disant que les
masques ffp2 ont montré leurs oeufs
avantage sur les autres masques
envisagez vous de les distribuer les
mettre à disposition gratuite aux
attentes des gens dont par exemple les
professeurs des écoles
chantal
madame la présidente monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
vous évoquiez il ya quelques instants la
possibilité d'une prise en charge à
domicile pour les patients dont
notamment dans l'état de santé de santé
nécessite de l'oxygène est ce que vous
pouvez nous confirmer que nous avons
assez de stock en matière d'oxygène
aujourd'hui en france suffisant parce
que ça ne fait pas partie des des
retours que nous avons ma deuxième
question pourquoi les délais de
réinjection varie tel régulièrement un
au départ vous nous parliez de cinq mois
4 mois 3 mois le directeur de la ms lui
même vient de mettre en garde sur cette
stratégie incompréhensible en précisant
leur répétition des doses n'est pas une
solution
qu'envisagez vous alors envisagez-vous
une quatrième une cinquième rang une
sixième dose et dans quel délai enfin
combien de lits de réanimation sont
effectivement disponibles aujourd'hui et
les ressources donc soignante
pourront-elles être mise donc seront
tels opérationnel pour s'occuper des
patients qui occuperont éventuellement
celi merci merci monsieur patrick anna
merci monsieur le prénom présidente
monsieur le ministre vous avez tout à
l'heure utiliser l'adage advienne que
pourra en général on le pressait de
l'expression fais ce que dois advienne
que pourra c'était
l'expression favorite de gaston
monnerville dans cette belle assemblée
fais ce que dois
depuis six mois deux comités de liaison
parlementaire en comité lisons
parlementaire vous me reconnaîtrez le
fait que je demande l'obligation
vaccinale au nom du groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présider
la réponse systématique de jean castex
ou la vôtre était mais non c'est
impossible à mettre en oeuvre et puis
nous sommes arrivés sur la notion
d'obligation déguisés pour reprendre
votre expression même si aujourd'hui où
il avait un petit peu je dirais timorés
au regard de vos explications ma
question et sa à monsieur ministres
le 30 juillet 2021 il y a eu il y avait
112 mille morts de lakovic 19 dans notre
pays sans doute une bonne
six mois plus tard nous sommes à 126
mille morts la question s'est elle est
très simple si l'obligation vaccinale
avaient été mises en oeuvre est-ce que
vous pensez que nous aurions pu éviter
une partie de ces morts
alors mélanie vos jacquet en visio et à
qui je souhaite la bienvenue puisque les
allées nouvelle la commission des
affaires sociales
merci bonjour merci de la bienvenue
monsieur ministre très rapidement tout
d'abord pour vous reposer la question
vous avez dit vous avez répondu à une
question qui vous avaient été posées sur
les dons de doses je crois que cette
question ne vous a pas été posée la
question qui vous avait été posée c'est
sur la levée des brevets je crois que
nous n'avons pas eu de réponse à une
question qui est très importante pour
nous je vous remercie de nous dire si la
france compte changer de position et
appuyer cette demande de certains pays
pour pouvoir produire eux mêmes les
vaccins et certains laboratoires des
centaines disent que c'est possible
la deuxième question c'est sur le profil
les personnes non vaccinées vous nous
aviez dit récemment qu ils sont divisés
grosso modo en trois catégories les
personnes isolées les personnes
indifférentes et les personnes
récalcitrantes réfractaires est ce que
vous auriez des chiffres un peu plus
précis à nous donner sur la composition
de la population non vaccinée
et enfin pour compléter la question de
mon collègue john je compte sur les
français et françaises qui sont à
l'étranger en dehors du problème qui
existe des personnes qui ont eu un
schéma vaccinal complet à l'étranger il
y a un problème avec des personnes du ru
le schéma vaccinal complet en france
mais qui résident à l'étranger et qu'ils
sont infectés à l'étranger et la france
ne reconnaît pas leur certificat de
rétablissement leurs tests pcr positif
et ces gens se retrouvent dans une
situation totalement aberrante
puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas faire de
troisième dose puisqu'ils viennent
d'être affectés donc c'est interdit ils
ne peuvent pas y avoir accès il ne vaut
mieux pas d'un point de vue sanitaire et
leur passé désactivé parce qu'ils n'ont
pas chez la troisième dose ce que vous
avez une solution à leur apporter je
vous remercie merci madame micheline
jack
est ou non aux questions
des questions
émilienne poumirol
est bon oui ça y est oui merci dame
présidente ministres juste une question
très bref puisque les questions de fond
on évoquera de nouveau en séance ou un
cas particulier de personnes qui ont
fait des réactions extrêmement
importante la deuxième injection de
vaccin
les réactions générales de jonathan
n'est donc pas simplement avec fièvre ou
autres juste après la deuxième injection
et qui ont été considérés par plusieurs
médecins en particulier au niveau de
l'hôpital et c'est le cas d'une
toulousaine qui m'a écrit encore ce
matin comme cas de coheed l'on est ce
que ces personnes là tout d'ailleurs
comme les gens qui sont co vie de long
placé kobe dont elles sont est ce qu'ils
seront exemptés du pass vaccinale merci
sur votre pardon
christophe-andré frassa merci monsieur
le président dans le prolongement de ce
que viennent de d'évoquer mes collègues
le comté et vogel je voudrais revenir
sur mes nos compatriotes qui ont un
schéma vaccinal complet ou incomplets
mais surtout pour ceux qui voulaient
établir un pass vaccinale
lorsqu'ils ont
contracté la maladie à l'étranger et
qu'ils ont un certificat de
rétablissement établi par une autorité
sanitaire
étrangères hors union européenne
sur le site des démarches simplifiées
à l'issue de la loi d'août et jusqu'au
mois d'octobre
il était indiqué que le certificat de
rétablissement vallée pour
l'établissement du pass sanitaires or
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on va sur le site des
démarches simplifiées il est indiqué
qu'en ne peut plus obtenir un pass
sanitaire avec un certificat de
rétablissement monsieur le ministre
est-ce qu'il est prévu que pour le pass
vaccinale pour tous nos compatriotes qui
vivent à l'étranger et qui auront besoin
pour se rendre en france et pour vivre
comme il se doit à l'aune de cette
nouvelle loi comme leurs compatriotes de
france et d et d'outre-mer avec un passé
un vaccinale est ce qu'il est prévu de
rétablir que certificat de
rétablissement puisse entrer dans le
cadre de l'établissement du pass
vaccinale véronique guillotin en
aiguille ottawa
oui bonjour merci monsieur mini de deux
questions rapides je suis dans une zone
frontalière je pense que vous savez j'ai
vacciner samedi matin et on a eu un
boost de primo vaccination car les
travailleurs frontaliers aujourd'hui au
luxembourg son sommet en fait de sarah
vacciner pour accéder au monde du
travail pour le 15 janvier je voulais
savoir s'il y avait des noms bassine à
récupérer si votre gouvernement envisage
qu'il envisageait ou et envisager
d'aller chercher des non vaccinés par la
suite dans le
pour l'axé l'accès au monde du travail
et la deuxième chose je reviens sur la
question qui était posée sur
l'harmonisation transfrontalière
concernant le pass vaccinale en effet la
maladie ou en tout cas la période de
rémission n'est pas considéré comme une
possibilité d'avoir un pass vaccinale
complet lorsque l'on suit la frontière
notamment au luxembourg
est ce qu'il y aurait une possibilité
d'harmoniser ses fins et autorisation de
passes vaccinale
merci des deux dernières questions
madame b du rova la belrhiti et après
c'est le ministre qui s'expriment mais
rssi beaucoup je voudrais relier la
question de ma collègue florence
lassarade à laquelle vous n'avez pas
répondu monsieur le ministre
est ce que le gouvernement entend aider
financièrement nos collectivités
territoriales dans l'achat
l'installation des purificateurs d'air
c'est une dépense supplémentaire qui
pèse encore sur les collectivités qui
ont démontré combien des invités est
essentielle pour cette dans cette crise
sanitaire merci
alors très rapidement tout d'abord je
voudrais savoir quelle est la définition
du statut des non vaccinés est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a reçu qu'une
injection ou avec un schéma vaccinal
incomplets ou considérés comme nos
effectifs car inférieure à 14 jours
serait-il possible d'avoir des données
affinées et plus détaillée
quelles sont les données plus précises
qui justifie la vaccination des rétabli
de nombreux médecins demandent quelles
données études justifie la vaccination
des rétabli alors même que de nombreuses
études montrent une réduction drastique
du risque de formes graves de plus de 90
% chez les patients rétabli par rapport
au patient sans antécédent de primo
infection réduction pérenne dans le
temps sachant que la prévention des
formes graves et maintenant le but
reconnu de la vaccination dont l'effet
de plus est un site transitoire enfin
les certificats médicaux des décomptes
de non contre indication de la
vaccination permet-il de bénéficier du
pass vaccinale afin de lever toute
ambiguïté sur la question
merci madame eh bien merci à chacun et
chacune d'entre vous a laissé la parole
au ministre pour sa réponse ou ses
réponses plus tôt
j'ai cinq minutes 4 minutes 30 alors là
je me serai présent pour répondre à 60
questions
je plaide la grâce de la commission et
me laisser l'opportunité peut-être de
déborder de quelques minutes je fais une
seule première réponse qui sera un peu
plus complète que les autres après je
serai split et des graphiques c'est sur
cette question d'immunité conférée par
la vaccination j'ai fait cette déjà
cette intervention à l'assemblée
nationale ça me semble utile de la
refaire vous avez si je globalise je
suis pas immunologiste deux types
d'immunité une humilité qu'on appelle
l'immunité humorale qui se traduit par
les anticorps des armes qui empêche les
cellules de rentrer dans les virus sont
rentrés dans les cellules humaines et
vous avez ce qu'on appelle l'immunité
cellulaire c'est la capacité de la
cellule a conservé dans la durée la
possibilité de fabriquer des armes
contre le virus si jamais le virus
rentrait deux types divinité ce qu'on
sait c'est que les vaccins arn messagers
actuelle fighter et moderna sont moins
bons en immunité une morale sur le
variant omicron mais reste très bon en
immunité cellulaire ça veut dire que on
est moins bon avec le vaccin pour
empêcher le virus de rentrer dans la
cellule donc pour empêcher l'infection
et la contamination
on reste très performant pour permettre
à la cellule de se battre efficacement
contre le virus une fois qu'il est
rentré pour l'empêcher de se multiplier
et de faire des formes graves c'est
pourquoi le vaccin les vaccins actuels
sont très performants pour limiter les
risque de formes graves mais il
n'empêche pas où ils empêchent - les
risques de contamination aux variants
omicron ça c'est important et ça répond
d'ailleurs une autre question qui est de
se dire pourquoi est ce que quand j'ai
un taux d'anticorps x ou y on va me
vacciner parce que votre taux
d'anticorps x ou y il ne reflète que de
votre immunité humorale combien
d'anticorps vous a vraiment donné dans
votre dans votre circulation mais ça ne
dit rien de la capacité de vos cellules
à fabriquer des armes en nombre
suffisant pour lutter contre le virus en
cas d'infection d'accord pour ça qu'on
n'a plus jamais utilisées sont pour les
immunodéprimés un taux d'anticorps pour
déterminer s'il y avait lieu ou non de
se vacciner mes demandes et les chiffres
précis je vous les donne sur le variant
omicron si j'ai été infectées et que je
ne suis pas vacciné c'est une protection
contre l'infection de 35% elle est de
55% si j'ai été vacciné deux doses et
allait de 85 pour cent si j'ai eu mon
rappel depuis moins de six mois voyez
déjà l'écart quand même un
contre l'hospitalisation si j'ai eu le
qu'ovide et que je ne suis pas vacciné
j'ai 80 % de risque de moins de faire un
de développer de faire une forme grave
dans les six mois 50% au-delà de six
mois de moins donc c'est une réduction
effectivement que j'ai une protection
qui est acté qui a acquise par
l'infection mais elle n'est pas totale
par contre j'ai eu mes deux doses ma
protection elle est de 90% dans les six
premiers mois contre l'hospitalisation
elle tombe à 70% date six mois c'est
pour ça qu'on fait un appel et c'est
pour ça qu'on réduit progressivement le
délai de rappel parce qu'on a
initialement ne savait pas au bout de
combien de temps et militer baisserait
maintenant on se rend compte qu'au bout
de trois mois ça justifie tient le
rappel pourrait remonter tout de suite
au-dessus de 90 % de réduction des
formidables et si j'ai eu mon rappel la
réduction des hospitalisations les 2 95
% voire six premiers mois et dans les
six mois d'après on sait par corps au
maximum parce qu'on n'a pas le recul
suffisant on estime qu'elle sera au
moins égal à 90%
toute la rhétorique sur vous avez
supprimé 5000 xterra je n'y reviens
parce que pardonnez moi je suis épuisée
d'y revenir à chaque fois d'expliquer
qu'on a pas fermé des lits
intentionnellement qui a des chambres
doubles qui sont devenues des chambres
au sol parce que madame la sénatrice si
vous étiez hospitalisé ce que je ne
souhaite pas dans une chambre double
avec un malade contaminé au co vide et
que vous n'êtes pas vous mêmes
contaminées au co bide vous serez je
pense assez soulagé du fait qu'on vous
dise que la chambre double ne devient
qu'une chambre sommes sol et donc quand
vous avez vingt mille malades
aujourd'hui hospitalisé pour qu vide
dans nos hôpitaux ça fait pour un
certain nombre de cas des chambres
doubles qui deviennent des chambres
simples ce conte dans un an on
identifiera comme vous avez fermé tant
de vies mais ce qui ne traduit pas la
réalité ni les raisons donc je propose
qu'on en sorte de 7,2 cette attaque là
qui était vraiment très courante sur les
nombre de lits de réanimation de la même
manière nous les augmentons nous les
avons pas diminué 700 lits
supplémentaires dans la durée ce qui est
un nombre de lits important en plus
alors qu' il faut 10 à 12 ans pour
former des anesthésistes et des
réanimateurs est pas un ou deux ans
comme je l'entends parfois certains
continuent a pris dans celle d'hier on
ne forme est évidemment pas un médecin
même diplômés aux techniques de
l'animation en un an ça prend beaucoup
plus de temps que cela sur notre
activité hospitalière on a doublé le
prix des heures sup on a doublé le
rachat des congés j'ai eu tout le ségur
je n'y reviens pas et j'y serai tout à
l'heure en vous quittant avec les i had
par exemple dans les suites du rapport
de l'inspection générale pour voir
comment faire évoluer leurs métiers
leurs compétences pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne propose pas de compenser les pertes
de rémunération des médecins dans le
secteur public parce que les mettant un
très grand public sont salariés et que
leurs salaires ne dépend pas de
l'activité ou des actes et donc il n'y a
donc pas de perte de revenus canton des
programmes des soins à l'hôpital public
sur kovacs l'union européenne c'est le
premier continent producteur est le
premier pays
le premier continent exportateurs de
vaccins l'enjeu n'est pas mais un
mécénat triste qui me poser la question
sur la levée des brevets l'enjeu est de
savoir combien de doses on est capable
de donner dans l'urgence avant de dire
que des pays pardonnez-moi mais des pays
qui sont en voie de développement vont
être capables de produire par eux-mêmes
dans des usines extrêmement complexe à
mettre en place des vaccins moi je
préfère qu'on me mette nos forces dans
la bataille pour leur livrer les vaccins
et l'autre gros enjeu on en parle peu
mais il est au moins aussi important que
le don de doses c'est comment est-ce que
ces doses sont utilisés une fois qu'elle
arrive parce que si vous n'avez pas
l'infrastructure logistique si vous
n'avez pas les personnes pour vacciner
si vous n'avez pas un système de santé
et si vous n'avez pas ne serait-ce que
des plans de communication sur la
vaccination pour avoir des vaccins mais
c'est compliqué de les utiliser or un
certain nombre de pays nous ont dit là
on est arrivé à saturation de ce qu'on
était capable de faire et donc on
travaille avec ces pays non seulement
leur donne des doses mon travail avec
ces pays pour leur permettre de
renforcer leurs capacités à vacciner sur
place sur la semaine une question m'a
été posée sur les tests payant sur la
semaine d'avant c'est le style pas
encore les chiffres sur la dernière soit
8 8 3 millions de tests réalisés 500000
été payant c'est à dire 7,8 millions
étaient totalement pris en charge oui
les vaccins s'améliore il ya ce qu'on
appelle des boosters ils sont capables
de tenir compte des nouveaux variants
ces discussions des laboratoires qui
communiquent que ce soit faiza robot
derna sur les perspectives de développer
des vaccins qui serait booster pour être
aussi efficace contre les contaminations
qu'il était contre delta avec des
variants issus du au micron s'il devait
y en avoir je lui ai répondu monsieur le
sénateur dans le débat parlementaire au
président le fur si vous avez un
certificat en bonne et due forme de
contre indication à la vaccination il ya
une validation qui est fait par
l'assurance maladie qui vous délivre un
retour un document muni d'un qr codes
avec intégration dans tout senti qu vide
au même titre qu'un pass
sanitaires ou impasse vaccinale n'y a
personne n'est lésé eux
j'ai marqué
vax débité à nom de max débuté à
l'étranger les règles du pass sont les
mêmes que celles du des règles en
vigueur actuellement avec le pass
sanitaire ça ne changera pas avec le
pass vaccinale définir
ah oui pourquoi est ce qu'on demande aux
préfectures de pouvoir accéder aux
chiffres de redonner de side up c'est
important ça pourrait qu'on demande aux
préfectures de pouvoir accéder aux
données sidec qui vous dit si les
patients sont contaminées ou non parce
que quand vous avez des mesures
d'isolement qui sont prononcés de
quarantaine le seul moyen d'être sûr que
la quarantaine a été respecté c'est de
pouvoir vérifier le moment où le test
qui permet de sortir de la quarantaine a
été réalisée c'est le salut c'est le
seul usage qui en sera fait si vous
l'autorisez
l'autorisation parentale pour les 5 11
ans c'est le conseil d'état qui nous a
demandé à restaurer une obligation
biparentales pour cette tranche d'âge si
la représentation nationale souhaite
aller vers une simplification elle en
est évidemment libre de le proposer
c'est une demande du conseil d'état qui
a dit pour les 5 à 11 ans la loi n'a pas
spécifié les choses donc cette par
défaut une victime une obligation
biparentales je suis à même la sénatrice
je serai demain en séance avec vous bon
pied bon oeil à 14h30 pour commencer
l'examen du texte on s'alternent aura
probablement avec mon secrétaire d'état
au gré d urgence sanitaire à gérer mais
je serai toujours avec vous même si je
ne suis pas tout le temps dans
l'hémicycle je serais plus que par la
pensée
puisque pas plus que par la pensée je le
serai aussi par le coeur voilà je serai
également aux questions au gouvernement
mercredi au sénat ben un seul un seul
être vous manque et tout est dépeuplé je
ne sais pas si je prie dans kenner veut
compléter ma citation
j'ai parlé du passage éventuel en auto
test pour simplifier la vie des parents
dans les écoles donc je ne viens pas
j'attends qu'on puisse peaufiner tout
cela et réfléchir combien de faux pas
190000 pourquoi leur tendance la
repentance ça permet à quelqu'un qui
était déterminé à ne pas sur vacciner et
donc à se procurer des faux documents de
se rendre compte qu'en fait il a fait
une grosse grosse bêtise et de pouvoir
et tout simplement de pouvoir de pouvoir
de pouvoir tout simplement être vaccinés
or si l' impasse en bonne et due forme
est qu un certificat de vaccination
bonne et due forme qui se présente dans
un centre va dire monsieur vous êtes
déjà vaccinées donc il faut qu'il puisse
dire en fait non j'ai triché et j'ai pas
été vaccinés vacciner moi s'il vous
plaît mon médecin m'avait trompé ou
machin avait trompé cta et là on ne
vaccine parce que l'essentiel c'est
effectivement
de les vacciner j'ai la gorge qui est
sèche rassurez-vous au bout d'une heure
et demie c'est pour ça que je tousse
haute alors
merci
on est bien au sénat
même posé la question des soignants non
vaccinés pourquoi est-ce qu'on empêche
les soignants doivent acter d'exercer
quand on pourrait mais permettrait à des
soignants cas positifs asymptomatiques
ou aussi symptomatique de travailler ses
deux deux cas d'exercice totalement
différent il ya l'exercice dans la durée
et l'exercice dans une situation
exceptionnelle dérogatoires où on aurait
vraiment pas le choix un soignant
positif qui sera amené à travailler
c'est la sphère de trois jours c'est
exceptionnel dans des services
particuliers est vraiment quand on n'a
pas le choix un soignant qui n'est pas
vacciné c'est tous les jours pendant la
vague ou en dehors des vagues donc c'est
différent et madame la sénatrice
quand vous êtes sénatrice de guadeloupe
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants est
a atteint le même niveau de complétude
qu'aux obligations vaccinales en
métropole c'est donc une très beau
signal et il y avait mille soignants ou
plutôt mille salariés d'établissements
de santé pas tellement de soignants donc
ses salariés qui n'étaient pas vaccinés
tous se sont vus proposer un entretien
individuel en vue d'aborder avec la
question de la vaccination et s'il ne
refusait d accompagner dans un
reclassement professionnel
625 ont accepté ce rendez-vous 300 ont
préféré partir 625 ont accepté ce
rendez-vous un tiers ont déjà été
vaccinés depuis et les autres sont pour
sûr sont sur la bonne voie pour y
arriver ou sont en campagne et donc
l'obligation vaccinale en guadeloupe se
passe je dirais de façon remarquable et
je salue notamment le directeur général
de l'hôpital monsieur collomb qui vous
le savez j'y reviens pas été victimes
d'agressions absolument scandaleuse la
semaine dernière j'en passe j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour passer un message à la
représentation nationale sénateur ou
député ou élus locaux ou prou
gestionnaires des centres ou soignants
qui travaillent dans les centres vous
avez le droit non seulement à la
protection non seulement au respect mais
vous avez le droit à l estime de la
population pour l'engagement qui est le
vôtre pour protéger les français c'est
exactement l'inversé de ce que montre
une partie très minoritaire de la
population qui s'en prend verbalement ou
physiquement aux gens qu'il devrait
plutôt remercier
sur la question du titre pourquoi on
parle plus propagation suit une
recommandation du conseil d'état parce
que la diffusion du virus est trop
importante au stade auquel nous nous
parlons est ce que le secteur privé
mobiliser oui les chiffres en attestent
ils sont très mobilisés la
recommandation du hsv est dû aux congés
pour la santé publique et les masques
ffp2 la recommandation a été remis ce
week-end je pense que nous allons la
publier ce soir ou demain et vous verrez
que c'est une recommandation qui portent
essentiellement sur les soignants et qui
je suis je résumais l'avis du hcsp n'est
pas vers une extension du port du fp de
y compris d'ailleurs dans milieu des
soignants au delà des soignants qui sont
aujourd'hui considérées comme à risque
parce que exposait des gouttelettes
c'est la recommandation du hcsp le
gouvernement aura évidemment à se
prononcer nous allons discuter de cela
on rendra publique la vie vous verrez
qu'on est assez loin d'après le hcsp
détendent le ffp2 à d'autres catégories
professionnelles
sur la question des stocks en oxygène
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure qui a au moins
quinze mille patients qu'on peut prendre
en charge en ville avec aux deux
extracteurs bouteille et si vous avez
entendu dire qu'on manquait d'oxygène
vous je veux bien falloir ou qui quand
et comment parce que ça nous permettra
de vérifier avec eux ou qu'on en a
mais on regarde région paca c'est un peu
vague si vous me donnez un nom moi je
veux bien qu'on l'appelle parce que vous
savez des fois on appelle les gens qui
sait pas si clair que ça
sur le nombre de lits en réanimation on
est à 6002 et le nombre de lits en
réanimation armée augmente au fur et à
mesure des besoins comme nous l'avons
fait au cours des vagues précédentes
je ne répondrai pas à votre question
monsieur kader qui me semble très
provocatrice sur combien de morts aux
réunions nous éviter en écoutant et
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale sur
l'eau ou au sénat sur le vaccin
obligatoire je vous ferai pas l'injure
de vous demander monsieur le sénateur
combien de morts nous avons évité en ne
suivant pas votre grande nation et en
prenant place en mettant en place des
mesures de couvre-feu de confinement de
jauge de limitation de circulation lors
des dix pjl précédent lors des tiges et
d'y pêcher le précédent les groupes
socialistes ont voté contre je crois que
c'est franchement pas à hauteur du débat
que nous avons eu deux notes après midi
sur la levée des breuvages et répondu
sur la reconnaissance du certificat de
rétablissement système si c'est au sein
l'union européenne que la contamination
a été constatée par tests biologiques
alors c'est considéré comme tel sans
problème si c'est hors de l'union
européenne ça dépend de notre capacité à
le démontrer on est en train de chercher
des solutions techniques paris des pays
dans lesquels on peut avoir plus ou
moins confiance dans la capacité de
quelques uns vont réaliser une pcr en
bonne et due forme et donc c'est cela
que nous travaillons évidemment pour
simplifier la vie des français qui est
vive où évoluent à l'étranger
et le passo vaccinale ou le pas
solitaire et le travail vous savez qu'on
avait abordé cette question les
partenaires sociaux nous tour demandé de
ne pas le mettre en place et qui n'avait
pas de consensus pas de capacité à
trouver un chemin et c'est pourquoi nous
avons opté sur le télétravail dont
l'efficacité comment je le disais en
préambule à être mesurable puisque il
semble qu il y a déjà un impact sur la
dynamique épidémique constaté depuis
quelques jours dans le pays avec toute
la prudence nécessaire
fin du monologue madame la présidente
monsieur le président merci pour votre
écoute
c'est monsieur le ministre à demain
alors
merci monsieur le ministre en cas de ma